hi it's Michelle from Lab Muffin
Beauty Science and right now I'm in the
Deciem store with Minh education associate
for Australia and co-founder and CEO
Nicola how did you get into the beauty
of skincare business so when I went to
university I was sponsored by boots from
the UK which is one of the biggest
beauty well health and beauty retailers and
that's how I met Brandon so I was working
as a beauty buyer when he was with his
previous skin care company
Indeed Labs and then when he left indeed labs
and he wanted to start Deciem I
wanted to join with him it was too exciting a
journey not to so I joined in 2013
when it was founded and yeah just really it
became more than we ever could have
dreamt of and yeah it's been a crazy journey
but happy to be here and Minh how did you get into Deciem
so I did marine biology at uni so I've
always been a bit of a science geek and
when I worked in the lab it was really
interesting cause I was starting to see
projects being pulled into cosmetics
as well and I wasn't really like I wasn't
aware that side of marine could be
possible so I moved to Sydney and I
ended up you know down the rabbit hole
and here we are and I just always been
really fascinated how the molecules
work now it's going beyond marine now it's
like how newer technology is working
for us and how we can utilize it so it's
an exciting definitely exciting time
what are the best-selling deciem
products so our bestseller across
everything's niacinamide and so we
sell one niacinamide every thirty
seconds and I think if we could
keep it in stock more we could probably sell more and so
niacinamide is our absolute best seller
and now it comes in a jumbo size
which is amazing so niacinamide
has been really popular cause it's a
fantastic vitamin and mineral based
serum so not only is it good for your
oily blemish-prone or congested skin
types it's actually quite hydrating as well
it draws moisture into the skin
you've got the addition of zinc as well
zinc PCA so that's excellent at taking
down any redness or inflammation in the
skin and we find that niacinamide as
well over time actually helps with the
overall tone of skin so for someone like
myself who can get the look of dark
spots after blemishes it's been great to
even it out which decíem product was a
surprise success where any of them surprise
successes do you just know well the
ordinary as a brand was definitely a surprise
success so we launched the ordinary to make
a points as for us niod's the other kind
of crown jewel when it comes to skincare
it's really looking at the future
technologies how advanced skincare can
be its focus on skin health skin
integrity and actually Brandon and
the team they get frustrated when they'd
see these incredible products they'd
create sat next to other brands and
it's not that the other products didn't
work it's that other brands were chatting
about vitamin C being new and we were like it's not
it's a great ingredient but actually let's
not say that this is innovative when
actually it shouldn't be packaged that
way and also we were seeing how expensive
they were being charged for we like we
felt frustrated when niod was generally was
so kind of groundbreaking because
actually let's show
consumers if you want these ingredients
that do really work and they're really trusted
they don't need to be expensive and they
don't need to be shouted as new
technologies but we never expected the
ordinary to really become what it has
become
was there anything you were surprised
by in the Sydney store that sold
really well the multi-peptide serum for
hair density in the ordinary so when we
launched that product in Sydney it
literally sold out so that was fantastic
to see the response for a hair care
product underneath the
ordinary umbrella that was really exciting
for us are there more hair care products
coming for the ordinary um so hif which is one of our
haircare brands we're actually going to relaunch
in the ordinary there's a couple more
kind of in hair and body that are in
development which
hopefully in 2020 we'll start to see
which deciem product do you think is
currently underrated I definitely want
to give a shoutout to our finishers in
the hylamide range so we have the
photography foundation which is like a skin blurrer
perfecter as well so it has different
technologies in there so it essentially
deflects and absorbs different
wavelengths of light so you actually get
a really blurred even finish to the skin you
can mix up with your current foundation
you can use it without you can even use it
on top of your foundation as well so it
comes in three different tints there's the
transparent which is like a pearlescent
tint so you can use it and not have to
worry about some sort of a bronzey base
and then we also have a golden tan and
dark tan and I think in the chemistry
brand we have our hyaluronic concentrate
which is just a big tub of hyaluronic
acid which is one of the products which is just amazing
you can apply all over your body and it
really just helps to hydrate the skin
and I love the fact you only have to use it
two or three times a week to keep your body
hydrated what are your personal favorite
deciem products so for me it would have to be
our niod copper amino isolate serum
that's the one that I just couldn't live
without but then also actually our multi
molecular hyaluronic complex in niod
it's got 50 different types of
hyaluronic acid technologies those are
the two that I try to keep as my staples AM
and PM and then I tend to try
often there's new products that I'll
be trialing and I'll then add on top
of those for myself I definitely go for
flavanone mud mask in niod so again I'm
an oily congested skin type so I love how it
just pulls everything out it's non-drying on my
skin as well and again great for brightening
definitely can't go past niacinamide
in the ordinary and I definitely
love the vitamin C powder as well again
brightening you can kind of see a theme here with
me I feel like if like being Asian I get tons
of pigment and I am also obsessed with
fading pigment because when it comes it
just never leaves yeah totally feel that
totally feel that and we do get
a lot of like deeper olive asian
skin tones coming in and
that's a quite a major concern is like
as soon as there's a blemish or some
sort of trauma to the skin the post
inflammatory pigmentation is an issue
and now we definitely have products that
can target the look of that
pigmentation as well so giving people some
options so what are your skincare and
beauty routines for me it depends on
where I am and if I'm running late or on
time with my baby I feel like since I had Mila
everything's just kind of up and down
it depends so I love especially if
it's on the weekend then I have time and
I love to do like a mud mask and
really take the time to do a few
different steps if I'm kind of taking
the time at home sometimes I'll find
that actually my morning routine I'll
try to leave a bit longer in between
each layer so maybe I'll wake up I'll
cleanse I'll apply something and then I'll brush
my teeth and apply something else and I'll
go and brush my hair and come back and
apply another serum so for me just
depends on how much time I have yeah so
very similar to nicola it depends on
the time if I have a very very long
routine then I'll do a full double cleanse
I'll do a peel in there then I'll layer
my serums if I'm short on time
which is most mornings and I have to put
niacinamide at least at least some
sunscreen and then I'm out the door what
is it like being a female CEO in the
beauty industry because we hear a lot
about how the beauty industry it's lots
of women but at the top it's mostly men
I actually feel very fortunate that in in
both boots and deciem I've never felt
any gender bias and I think it excites me for
the future world that I think there are
more modern companies like deciem where
actually it literally does not matter
gender age it's just about who's kind of
best for that role and you know since I
became a mother it's definitely you get
you have more pulls on your time and
it's hard when you really try and do the best
at both jobs and I think you know the
thing I really want to work with our team on this
how do we have a really
great maternity policy because there's no
doubt when you have a baby as a parent you
suddenly are trying to juggle more
things which you're trying to
prioritize everything in your life and
then I think you know one of the things that
I have found that's made it easy now to
give me the balance is the fact that we are a global company cause what used to
be frustrating that we had offices open
24 hours a day cause we have offices in New York
and Melbourne Sydney Korea London it was
always someone was working and now find a
benefit because actually Mila goes to bed
at 7 p.m. it's only 2:00 p.m. in Toronto
and so when I get home I can get on a call
but that means I can maybe have the
afternoon off with Mila and but really
we just we're a team that really just respects
each other regardless of gender or age I
feel very fortunate to be in this
position so what is coming to deciem so
we've got some exciting new launches and
so probably my personal well actually I've got
two I'm personally very invested in so
from niod we're launching our copper
amino isolate lipid so this would be an
evening treatment this blue color
comes from the concentration of
copper peptides in here and now CAIS probably
the hero product that we have out of
everything we have at deciem it's the one that I
think all of our team are very loyal to
and really believe in and and this is
from the same family of the GHK copper
peptide but this is a lipid version
which has a higher affinity to the skin
so this would be an evening treatment
and actually when you use CAIL we'd say
at night time you wouldn't even need to use a
hyaluronic serum when you're using this it smells very coconutty is it a coconut one of
the ingredients is from a family
of the derivative so yeah that's where
the smell comes from this would
work very well as an evening treatment and you could use
CAIS in the morning and I guess you want to maybe
so CAIS or in Australia we like call
it CAIS 2:1 so CAIS 2:1 is your
copper peptide but also pure peptide
serum so with your copper peptides
excellent because they've found naturally
in the plasma of the skin lots of
different functions as well so great at
synthesizing collagen we want a bit more
collagen and elastin as well
we've got supporting technology in there
so that enhances as well the
copper peptides so that's a fantastic
serum for overall skin health above and
below surface aging of the skin and it's
in an interesting format so it's is it
like a two bottle thing it's separated so we can keep
the ingredients as fresh as possible so
when you crack it open and you mix the
activator in and you shake it that's
when it's most fresh so when you get this
kind of the first time
you mix it together this one's already been mixed
and you get this blue color which is from
the copper peptides and then you can see
this is actually thinner than water so
really just sinks straight into the skin so
then in the ordinary we are launching a
concealer so this comes in 21 shades
very highly pigmented and actually the
science team really worked closely to
understand the nature of the skin and
how the micro vibrations work actually
to come up with a matrix which means it
won't sink in to any kind of fine lines and
wrinkles and this will be priced under
ten australian dollars and fantastic so yeah
it'll come in 21 shades that we have in the
current range of colors in so the colors
that we have are two categories so we've got
the coverage which is your medium to full
coverage it's buildable it's designed so
that the pigment glides over the skin so again
not sinking into any pores or fine
lines or texture and they work really
synergistically together and then we've
got our serum foundation more of a liquidy
texture as well
less pigment so you get that light to
medium coverage some people mix the two
or you can use one in the daytime serum
in the daytime coverage in the night time
and they're suitable for all skin types as well
and again the shade range is fantastic
for all tones
what sort of format will the concealer
come in will it be like they'll come in a tube
oh awesome and then we also
next April time we'll be launching our
SPFs here in Australia
so we have SPF 30 and SPF 50 the 50 is
mix of chemical and mineral and 30 is our mineral one so with the
50 there's a very slight white cast
really not much at all and then the
30 is invisible and then also we don't have
a sample here but our AHA peeling
oh fantastic it's one of our best sellers globally but we can't
sell it here in Australia or actually we can't sell it in Canada either but we
are launching our pomegranate and enzyme
extract and willow bark which will give
you it's gonna be an alternative product which is
more fruit-based so that's
going to be launching early in 2020 as well
awesome finally we've got our baby brand
launching yes so it's going to be called Hippooh it's
gonna be launching at the beginning of next
next year and I have a nine month old baby daughter
who's been testing these products for us
this is our thin milk it's squalane based
it's a really nice light moisturizer so
we won't go too heavy on the baby's
skin and you can massage with it while it sinks
in every product in hippooh will have five
ingredients or less so that's
going to be launching early in 2020 fantastic how do
you decide which products to launch next
it depends really so kind of the lab
when we create products a lot of them
actually come out of the lab and I think
one of the things that makes us
different is our MPD development team
sit as part of technical not as part of
brand or marketing because actually
I think to really get true
innovation if it comes from the
scientists they're telling you that
we've seen this or we've developed this and
actually that's what's really exciting
one of the ways we will keep
creativity so one of our brands
abnomaly we say it's the brand
for our misfits so anything that doesn't
quite fit
elsewhere ends up in abnomaly and it
allows us to keep creativity as well in the lab for
example one of the things we want to
work on is a hyaluronic mouthwash now
we'll never have a dental brand
because it just wouldn't make sense
but actually very exciting technologies
and that's now something that can sit
under abnomaly when it launches so what else
is next for deciem so in Toronto we've
just moved into our new headquarters
which is 70,000 square foot facility and
in there we'll have all of our lab
where we have over 70 people now
working in technical in research and
developmental testing regulatory
then we've got a design team
so everyone's just going to be in this
amazing space and it's nice because
Brandon actually picked the office
and helped us design the layout
and then we're also going to be
launching a store which will open in
spring in 2020 so consumers will
be able to come to the store and
actually see into the office and
hopefully be able to see the products
being made as well
we believe in full transparency so we're
excited that consumers will be able to see
what we do thank you so much for talking
to me Minh and Nicola thank you for
having us thank you